hello and welcome to this video Sokka
novita support ok go oops no Roxy bind
probably or there there's some funny
lines now but he goes for mainland
Barack see ya always happy to keep the
pieces on the bottom with them 92
yeah happy to get that opening don't not
playing great in this session and then
conceded many points so i'm happy that i
get an opening like the maroc see that I
know reasonably well hmm so like already
has allowed some things that usually
should not be allowed c4 c5 not going to
be hectic here just trying to improve
the position a little bit more so yeah I
don't like to take now but maybe have to
hmm
yeah batik my cheeks that isn't so bad
for him even though he lost like five
moves also maybe Luke see one was just
too lame hmm Wow Jim don't really know
what what I did wrong yeah okay well
maybe it was too lame that's it it's
really possible like be three okay
whatever check it wasn't the most
ambitious way to play wit didn't see
anything brilliant
hmm yes equalised my god after this
opening okay 95 maybe
yeah after 98 c7 black really shouldn't
equalize anymore c5 should be right but
maybe that rook see one was just just
bad kind of a non-moving away didn't do
much
you got absolutely zilch am you cannot
play b6 but it's not a big deal s
position is completely safe
okay eh 4G 4G five hmm man I have
nothing absolutely nothing where is he
going to have six maybe I'm not sure h/h
five if that is an idea we cannot take
but ok
when you can equal to state on d6 Knight
f6 is also ok here still not doing much
well then I don't know about what's that
necessary really it's also so Bishop c4
orbit so I think I'll take I think it
cannot be bad we're sending is pawn
structure there Bishop c4 Bishop your
form also g4 is good I'm going g4g 45
and King at 14 g5 trying to enter yeah
should be four here let's do that
h5 is coming the rook on the fifth rank
is doing some good job I wonder if no
now you cannot play 9595 Bishop takes
rook see if I this Bishop chicks is 6i
guess this one okay let's check that
check is still somewhat irritating and I
can go here all night be five lap okay
that's not a problem african king see
form but I still should have seen the
move should have seen the move before
each five maybe if five chicks 96 that
could be an issue but okay if I can go
King c4 it's not Wow there should be
seven kami check also looks bad that
looks bad
so what now I cannot move the night
maybe gain some more space look at five
I can take it's not a problem I think
and now would be six would be seven
maybe time morning
ultimately that's h5 I got King c8 after
Ruby seven that's not doing that much
Danny maybe I have to do it differently
I know I don't have bishops is 62 to get
five and they're not playing this well
maybe I can just play no I cannot anyway
I need to do stuff to make some headway
here
should do I stop that I hope I stop it
and there should be six I should stop
the poem check check black for fits on
time oh yeah that was a pretty yeah that
was really a disappointing I mean he
played this nightie aid and 97 and
pretty much rented to see fire and I
simply didn't review it Eric see one was
a quick routine move but yeah I have to
do something different he really
shouldn't get out of this I should get
more at least the computer wants to do
this but also only gives white 0.8 0.9
it's not a decisive advantage bishop is
six and then this which also doesn't
look very intuitive job okay it looks
nice but most surprised that here I
don't really have anything the engine
wants to play before which I couldn't
really make work I thought this would be
okay ah ok this move I didn't see and
while is somewhat better okay yeah this
was absolutely man yeah it's just
equally I think David now I'm started to
get little things I mean very little and
he went is 6 and this is not necessary
at all check and TX takes and probably I
should take I should trade on c8 yeah
the computer is very clear that this
wins yet it is
obvious actually I guess I go here and
just win window win the house right
pretty bad yeah now I'm still struggling
yes yes this would have been okay for
him according to the comp I can still
continue of course but it's something
like this black probably shouldn't lose
that's not fun but you have very decent
shot is to hold after this however i'm
i'm winning not doing it very
convincingly but it is a lot better than
wild down here cheap on g point does win
chan knew if he goes to da I can do this
I'm stopping the pond yeah are not very
convincing but I'm glad to get a win it
thanks for watching